[Music]
i could not be more fired up that my
first guest is somebody who i consider a
terrific friend and a legend uh in the
business of uh
calling sporting events and a voice of
generations
and i say that um fully aware that again
uh that allows me to pick up dinner the
next time here on just getting started
is none other than the voice of sunday
night football
al michaels how are you sir i'm
fantastic rich thank you very much and
i'll leave the tip you can pick up the
uh the rest of the tab i am genuinely
excited about this conversation al
because the number of times i've had
talks with you about how you got started
in your career and the stories that you
tell
not only um just uh around the dinner
table but uh in your fantastic
memoir um you can't you just can't make
this up did i get that right did i screw
up one of the names and
it's um
it's
[Laughter]
i i love your stories so i'll i'll just
get right into it al with you um
how did you just get started in your
career how did it all well i have to go
all the way back to uh
growing up in brooklyn i grew up 10
blocks from ebbets field when the
dodgers were still playing
in brooklyn and my father walked me over
to ebbets field one saturday afternoon
when i was probably six or seven
it's the first thing i remember in life
i remember walking in and you know the
grass was so green and
vin scully always talked about the
dodger uniforms being wedding cake white
silent signage on the outfield walls
you know the oregon is playing the whole
thing jackie robinson is actually in
that game
duke snyder gil hodges
and a lot of the great dodgers
of the past
and i remember thinking i want to be
here every day this is the greatest
thing in the world so my father was a
big sports fan
we lived within walking distance of
episode and so i grew up with the
brooklyn dodgers knowing
i wanted to be in the ballpark every day
and then as i got a little older
realized i could get in for free
by getting a job as maybe the
broadcaster for the dodgers or some team
down down the line so that was the
genesis
of uh
of my love for baseball my love for
sports my father took me to hockey at
madison square garden the old garden to
the football giants playing at yankee
stadium also we had remember the new
york baseball giants and yankees were
playing there so we had three teams in
new york so he could take the subway to
the polo grounds yankee stadium so
that's how i grew up and the nba when it
only had eight teams at madison square
garden so you'd you'd have a double
header and four teams would come in on a
saturday afternoon so i knew rich
exactly what i wanted to do from the
time i was probably seven years old and
how how did you go about it um about
getting your start about making this
dream
of
talking sports broadcasting sports how
did you make that happen
when it came time to pick a college i
went to high school we moved to los
angeles ironically the same year that
the dodgers did so i never missed a beat
so the dodgers at the coliseum but it's
now time for me to go to college
and my father and i looked at colleges
at that point that had
radio stations
and or tv stations that allowed students
to broadcast games there were very very
few of them
i liked living out west i didn't want to
go back east
usc was one of the schools and arizona
state was another of the schools that we
we researched and sc was in town i
wanted to have the experience of going
away to college so i i chose arizona
state
and we made a trip down there when i was
a high school senior we talked to the
people at asu
and they said you know at some point as
a student i'll
get to announce some games on the campus
radio station
which of course had a radius of like
four blocks unless you were in the uh
the women's uh the boiler room at the
dorm you couldn't pick the thing up but
it gave me a lot of experience i go down
to school and i wind up doing
four years of baseball
basketball football i'm the sports
center of the
the campus newspaper and one of the
great stories from me rich was that as a
freshman in 1962 i go down there
long registration line probably 45
minutes before we can get to
the place where we need to start filling
out the forms
and i started a conversation with the
kid in front of me
who was a freshman
from the cleveland area and he was there
on a baseball scholarship
and i tell him what i want to do and i
hope to have the opportunity to
broadcast some of his games his dream of
course is to play baseball see where
that goes
ten years later
i'm announcing for the cincinnati reds
he's the third baseman for the oakland
days we're both a part of the world
series sal bando
oh yes so sal
sal and i had that conversation
in a registration line
and then i would go on to
eventually get the reds job when i was
27 years old
and sal plays third base for the
soon-to-be three-time champion oakland
a's who beat the reds in the world
series in 72 and
won it again in 70 73 and 74. so sal and
i go back all the way
the following year a guy named rick
monday comes to school
and rick had a pretty good career and
still broadcast the dodger games and
then when i'm a a junior a freshman
comes along by the name of reginald
martinez jackson the one and only reggie
jackson so we went all the way back the
coach was bobby winkles who would wind
up managing in the majors with oakland
and california and coaching for several
teams so that's right that's where i
really cut my teeth in
broadcasting well i mean and i gotta
have you tell this story by the way i
had no i i did not know about that story
but you have to tell the story about how
you called minor league games in hawaii
that i guess eventually did lead to the
the job that you just referenced in
cincinnati i assume that's exactly what
happened so when when i i get out of
college
and i now i get married i met a girl in
the 10th grade and you know her very
well linda michaels you know she's still
in the next room right now
uh so that worked out pretty well and
then
we uh
i was looking for a job so i wrote to
all of the
minor league teams major league teams
nba teams in fact the phoenix suns were
starting up and i had just graduated and
i wind up trying to get the phoenix
sun's job he said i just want to get
into broadcasting and the guy who's
going to run that team is a guy named
jerry colangelo who is like 27 or 28
years old i'm in his office which is in
a trailer at the veterans memorial
coliseum in phoenix before the phoenix
suns ever play a game and jerry couldn't
have been greater i mean it could go all
the way back and i feel like you know
forrest gump
from time to time but anyway i go to so
i wrote to all the teams
my father-in-law happened to have a
business
in hawaii and i'm you know i'm getting
you know responses oh you know we wish
you well blah blah blah blah but there's
no job that's forthcoming and he says to
me hey come with me to hawaii or meet me
in hawaii come over you know for three
or four days i know some people over
here there's a minor league team
so i reluctantly did i wanted to do
everything on my own but i went over
there and he introduced me to a an
advertising executive who introduced me
to a man by the name of jack quinn who
was the general manager
of the hawaii islanders baseball team
aaa pacific coastly
and uh i got an audience with with jack
quinn
i gave him a reel to real tape from
arizona state this is in february of 68
uh and he says oh you know good luck
we'll stay in touch
thinking you know he won't stay in touch
but
on the cusp of the season in 68
his primary announcer a guy named marty
chase
was in a reserve unit that had been
called active duty so i get a call on
the eve of the season from jack quinn
who said can you come over here and
announce a few games
and
and that led to
doing three years of the hawaii
islanders university of hawaii football
and basketball high school football and
basketball is gigantic i was on
television
twice a day on the abc affiliate there i
got
15 20 years experience
in three years because in football i
would do five games a weekend four high
school games
and a college game anyway the hawaii
islanders we were the uh
california angels farm club
68 69 and 70
and
what happened was we wound up drawing
about a half a million people we were
the most successful minor league team
our manager chuck tanner winds up
getting the white sox job beginning in
71. the farm director for the angels
roland heman winds up going to chicago
the long time general manager those guys
actually tried to get me to chicago to
be the announcer there so they went to
chicago it's now after their season in
in
1970
and the owner of the team is a guy named
john allen a-l-l-y-n
listen to the tape i've got tanner and
heman trying to get me to chicago
there's an opening there he tells them
look this this kid sounds pretty good i
can't bring a 25 26 year old kid into
chicago and make him the number one
announcer in the number two market which
chicago was at that time
so i'm very very disappointed but then
about a week and a half later out of
nowhere comes a call from the cincinnati
reds from a man by the name of dick
wagner the number two guy to bob
houseman
and the structure there
can you come to cincinnati uh we want to
talk to you they heard about me
uh somebody had sent them an audition
tape i go to cincinnati i get the job
and here i am at the age of 26 years old
i'm the announcer for the big red
machine with pete rose in his prime
johnny bench coming into his prime
tony perez in his prime david concepcion
the older ken griffey would get there in
73 and joe morgan getting traded over in
72 and that's how i wind up
on the world series in 72 because in
those years rich
nbc would use the primary announcer for
the
teams that are in the series
the home team guy would do his his games
in like in cincinnati i did the games in
cincinnati in oakland i did uh nbc radio
and that's how i wound up doing the
world series and that's how i wound up
doing the series and
and and announcing my uh my college
friend sal bando playing third base with
the ace unbelievable i do have to
you know before you move on to the nfl i
i gotta linger here your best sparky
anderson story i mean what was it like
being around him managing the big red
machine rose give me give me your
give me your go-to give me your one of
your favorites being around this
register the greatest thing for me in
cincinnati is that i had to do
a show with sparky every day for 10
minutes they called it the main spark
so sparky he he could have been greater
and sparky was only about maybe 37 38
years old at the time and he looked like
he was you know 100 b sparky always who
was withered with the white hair
i got my phd from sparky because not
only did we have to do this show we did
600 of these shows we did every spring
training game every regular season game
all 162 and then we were in post season
two of the three years so i truly did
about 600 shows with sparky
so you had 10 minutes so we had to be
alone and then he would oftentimes close
the door
uh we would tape the show and then we'd
sit there and talk
for another 20 minutes you know off mike
so i i learned so much from sparky and
pete rose
i always made it a point we were on the
road
on the bus i would try to sit next to
pete because he could go through the
entire game pitch by pitch telling me
exactly what he thought exactly what he
was thinking yet him he had johnny who
knew everything morgan comes over i mean
man oh man i'm i'm going to harvard
oxford cambridge princeton and yale all
at the same time it's just amazing and
then you got to tell quickly uh or
however you wish the story about uh you
getting a recommendation to the dodgers
organization
through your calling games
in hawaii and who is the one who did it
and how i love this is maybe one of my
favorite stories i've ever heard you
tell
al please tell it go for it well
and of course it involves the the great
tommy lasorda so in hawaii our big rival
in 1968 69 70 was the spokane indians
the indians were the dodgers aaa farm
club
so and those were the spokane indians
that had bobby valentine
bill buckner steve garvey bill russell
baby lopes these were the dodgers of the
70s playing in spokane
because of travel and how expensive it
was when a team would come to hawaii
they'd be there all week he'd play seven
games
so i got to know
the spokane indians because they'd come
over twice for two seven game series
the manager is tommy lasorda and lasorda
used to love to tell this story he
embellished it a little bit
but most of it is true so he would get
on the phone after every game and al
campanis was the dodger general manager
and he'd report back he'd go al you know
here's what valentine did tonight and
garvey went two for four and russell did
this here's how the pitchers did
so it's i think the sixth game of a
seven game series and he
toward the end of the conversation he
says uh hey out the campanis you know
this i know you've got vinnie and
scully's great he's going to be there a
long time there's this this kid over
here in hawaii this guy's announcing the
games this this guy's really good this
this kid al michaels i'll tell you what
he's just keep an eye on him
so they continue the conversation and
then at the end of the conversation
campaign assistant was sort of
this michael's kid this guy you're
talking about how do you know he's any
good tommy says i've been thrown out of
the last four games i've been sitting
out in the clubhouse listening to him
so what really happened was lasorda gets
thrown out in the third inning of like
the third game of the series now in the
fourth game of the series she's so mad
from the night before he gets thrown out
with the line up court now in hawaii you
don't go behind the dugout to the
clubhouse the clubhouse is 100 feet
beyond the center field fence it's a 500
foot walk and you're being serenaded so
he's long gone he can't sneak back in he
truly is in the clubhouse listen he's
the fifth game i think he stays in the
game the whole the whole way the sixth
gaming is thrown out about the fourth
thing so he's thrown down a three out of
four now you talk about
you can't believe where you are
the umpire who threw him out of those
games was bruce fremming who would go on
to to umpire 37 consecutive years in the
national league so we go all the way
back unless i use whenever i got an
award i would have to bring the sword in
to tell the story tommy was one of a
kind i love it he's thrown out with a
line of cards so he gets to actually
hear you call the action so you actually
know he he he knew it oh god i love that
story so how how did you get to football
how did that come around to you finally
getting to the sport which is amazing
you know obviously
you know your your baseball uh
uh career got you into national
broadcasting and then obviously you
called so many games on the national
level including the famous earthquake
game but
also the miracle on ice is something
that is with you forever but you are
legitimately the voice of the nfl and
have been for a very long time how did
you get to
that chair well in hawaii again i go
back to doing five games a weekend
for high school and a college game for
three years so by the time i left hawaii
i had probably called 150 football games
and i called all the football games when
i was a student at arizona state so
i had truly called like 200 football
games by the time i get to the
cincinnati reds
who let me when the season was over
do a couple of regional
games football games for nbc so i
actually did in october of 71 on a
point-to-point telecast i did buffalo at
minnesota and two weeks later because
kurt gotti was tied up with baseball
i did buffalo at the jets so my first
two nfl games were in 1971
going just to to the
hall market or actually the road market
because it was blacked out in in the
home cities at that point
so i do that and one
johnny
my first uh partner was johnny morris
the wide receiver for the bears who
still owns a lot of those records if you
hear me talking about johnny when we do
a bears game it's because you know
johnny and i go all the way back and
then a guy named dave kosurick did the
second game with me but what happened
was when i
i leave cincinnati after three years one
of the reasons i left the primary reason
is i go to san francisco they triple my
salary so that's number one but number
two the giants were willing to let me
miss games during the football season at
the end
to do
to do football games on our regional
basis
so in 74 i did about eight or nine
regional games for
nbc
and then we couldn't make a deal for 75
we're talking about in those years like
the difference between like 750 and a
thousand bucks a game as ridiculous as
that sounds and i went to cbs for a year
and that led to
in 76
when abc started monday night baseball
they called me and i wound up doing the
b game which led to me being at abc
full-time for 30 years and i eventually
wound up doing the number two game on
college football behind keith jackson in
the late 70s and early 80s and that led
to the nfl in 86 it was a long
roundabout way that
that i got there doing some regional nfl
games in the early 70s a lot of college
games between 77 and 85
and then to monday night football for 20
years beginning in 86. so uh a few
strands to pull on here so does that
mean there is a cbs sports blazer
in your in in your past al did you ever
get one of those for your one year at
cbs i'm not sure i got one and i
certainly would not have kept it because
don cricky and i were the only guys in
1975 who did not get a postseason
assignment and we were you know we
didn't even get the sun bowl and don and
i talked about that through the years i
mean everybody else on the staff wound
up you know getting an assignment it was
you know the one thing i do remember
about the cbs years i among my partners
that year was the late wayne walker uh
johnny unitas i did a game with johnny
onitis
johnny mara johnny morris was now at cbs
i did a game with him
and then i wound up doing like the last
five games of that season with hank
stram and we had a blast
we loved it and then hank
hank had been fired
by the chiefs he goes to cbs
we do you know he they were moving
partners around left and right so i'd
hang for like four or five games at the
end of the season
and then hank goes back to coaching the
saints
a wonderful man i love tank and uh
there's nobody who could who could tan
more easily than hanks ram who used to
be sitting out by the pool with bear
grease on in one of those uh tin foil
reflectors
but he was the beauty i loved i loved
old henry
what was it like doing a game with
united was he was he good at it
he
was okay
you know first of all i mean wow i
couldn't believe i'm doing a game with
johnny and knight
are you kidding me
uh
but uh he he was he was fine to work
with but he was you know he he didn't
have a lot of experience i'm not sure
johnny did more than one or two seasons
of some regional games with him but the
interesting thing the one game i did
with united in the 75 season
was new orleans at oakland
and i was living in the bay area at the
time which i was doing the giants
and i drove over to go to the raiders
practice
uh in alameda
uh during the middle of the week and
that's the first time i met john madden
and i sat in john madden's office in
1975 and he was a big baseball fan so
he's talked a lot about baseball he
listened to the giants you know i knew
my work uh and then we talked about we
talked about everything talk about how
much we love travels with charlie by
steinbeck and then john talked about the
fact that one day what he wanted to do
is you know get a camper just go around
the country so of course he coaches he
coaches the raiders he wins the super
bowl he has you know the best record of
any coach in history percentage-wise who
who coached 10 or more seasons and then
he didn't quite get that camper but of
course he got the madden cruiser and
that's how john saw the country for you
know three decades so he was talking
about the madden cruiser a long time as
the madden camper first before he was
the best camper that's exactly right
and he he would be at the wheel but john
and i that's the first time i met john
uh and we saw each other irregularly
through the years and then of course
we became partners between 02 and 08 and
i had seven wonderful wonderful seasons
with coach madden okay and so the uh be
doing the baseball games with abc and
obviously you said college football
uh you you meet you meet keith jackson
what what was what was he like al
walk me through the voice of college
football
uh for all those years after obviously
when you first met him he wasn't that
but he became that everybody forgets
this certainly anybody of a certain age
is when monday night football started he
was the original play-by-play announcer
so monday night football in 1970 was
keith jackson
howard cosell
and don meredith but rooney garlage
whose concept this was always wanted
frank gifford one of his great and good
buddies
in new york and gifford couldn't get out
of his contract at cbs in 1970 and it
wasn't until 71. so keith gets bounced
from monday night football after one
season and he was never after that a
really big fan of rooney can understand
why but roon attempted to make it up to
him
by eventually
giving keith the number one game in
college football which at that point i
think chris schenkel was actually the
number one announcer before i got there
and by the time i got there keith had
now ascended to the number one role
on college football so keith and i you
know because we're doing we're doing
games on the same day really never did
got to cross paths a lot
but keith was uh
keith had a way with words
uh that was so unique and so different
and i mean one of the one of the
greatest lines
i've ever read
keith had done a uh
an interview with a student newspaper at
the university of oregon
toward the end of his career
and uh it's a q a and they talk about
keith you know you've done the olympics
and you did monday night football and
you've done all the great college
football games you did
baseball on the world series
is are there any more goals
and keith's answer was just one
i don't want to die in an airport
parking lot
that was quintessential keith you know
the big uglies in the trenches back to
the old and tangy river here in columbus
ohio keith had a way with words i mean
it's just it just it flowed
that is fantastic al i've never heard
that one before oh so and then obviously
you mentioned his name and
so you
one give me your first meeting with
howard so in
1977 now i joined abc full-time i'm
going to do the b game on
monday night baseball i'm going to do
some college football at that point and
a lot of wide world of sports shows
so that we were doing a ton of boxing in
those years
and they had an event called the united
states boxing championships
don king was promoting it and there was
all kinds of
chicanery going on behind the scenes and
congress is about ready to look into
this but cosell was doing that package
until all of a sudden it looks like
this is going to be a congressional
investigation
so in march of 77
uh i am ready to leave home on a friday
and i am going to do the pro boulders
tour
i think in st louis because because
chris schenkel who did that was in
kissfield austria covering
covering skiing
i get the call at home as i'm on my way
to the airport going go to san antonio
immediately why
so no no because we may have a problem
tomorrow and we need you to help solve
this problem
for the u.s boxing championships so i go
to san antonio and costello is already
there but now they're going to take him
off the show because they don't want him
affiliated with this nefarious concept
right i mean the the records were being
rigged and king was doing all kinds of
stuff behind the scenes what else is new
so um
i go into i'm not even sure i'm going to
be on the air the next day
abc is still deciding whether to take
howard off and put me on as kind of a
sacrificial land because nobody knew who
i was or or cared at that point
so i met howard
at dinner and uh the crew was out there
producer director you know two or three
other guys and he couldn't have been he
couldn't have been nicer and uh and that
was that was the good howard so we had
fun and i think he
he took a liking to me because he he saw
in me a guy who
as i would like to say i had a little
bit of rascal in him you know and i was
not going to
go down the straight and narrow and i
still don't i think richie you know i'm
i'm careful with where i go but you know
i like to have some fun and i think
howard saw that in me and uh he took a
liking to me at first and then of course
uh
down the line we wound up doing a ton of
baseball together he is one of the
reasons why i do what i do
watching howard cosell
um
do monday night football
and just hearing him
be somebody who wasn't as you know he
used to rail against the jockocracy
um and and he wasn't somebody who that's
the name of his book you know i know
your book is you can't make this up and
his book was i never played the game or
one of them and i i i kind of saw
you know a jewish kid growing up in new
york i saw somebody who wasn't
an athlete didn't play
but get to talk at the highest level and
also say things
um i he had me literally at hello howard
cosell he took it to the edge he was the
first guy to really take it to the edge
and he was look when you do that
you're going to be an extremely
polarizing figure
and that's what he was and i think there
was an article in tv guide maybe in
around 1980 where he was the most
admired and the most loathed
sportscaster
of his of his generation so you loved
him or you hated them
but howard was he was of a of a
different ilk
and
and you're right there's no question he
i think he made it easier for certain
people to get in and do certain things
that they weren't able to do until that
time now of course we've taken it
completely we've blown the top off
everything where anything goes these
days and and howard wouldn't be uh he
wouldn't be a a unicorn today but but he
was
one of the most fascinating human beings
i've ever met
he could be everything from charming
to cantankerous i saw all sides of him
he was a lot of fun in the early years
and he wasn't very much fun at the end
he got he became very bitter toward the
end and it was
it was a very inglorious departure
from abc and from network television but
at that point you know howard had just
he'd grown tired he really had and uh uh
it's too bad that it wound up the way it
did but but
unfortunately it was not the departure
that everybody wanted to see from him
and so i guess before we just dive fully
into the rest of our interview into the
nfl
uh your best uh wide world of sports
assignment give me give me that one
early on yes i saw one of my first trips
to europe i'd never been to europe until
i joined abc and now they've sent me
over there like every other week it was
fantastic it truly was the wide world
and you got to see it
so i get assigned to an event in india
west germany
at that time germany was
separated and
in the bavarian alps and it's
motorcycles on ice
which was
a wide world of sports staple in those
years and so it was a quarter mile
track which was used for speed skating
and for like regular track meets in the
summertime but in the wintertime it's
all iced over
and uh
you have a bunch of eastern europeans
and uh
and russians at that point
and bulgarians and romanians and
it was
these are the guys who were competing in
this no no westerners
and they would get on motorcycles on
motorbikes and go around this quarter
mile track x number of laps with a bunch
of spikes coming out of the tires and
that's how they got the traction and
they did this in front of 10 000 wild
and woolly
bavarians and they would start it at
about eight o'clock at night we were
taping it in those years and uh but but
the the the tailgating would be starting
at about three o'clock and the shops is
blowing i mean it's just flowing
so
it's one of the great stories so jeff
mason is the producer become a great
friend but i but uh jeff had you know
has had a fabulous career
he says why don't we do something
different for the scene set instead of
you coming on in the yellow blazer blah
blah blah blah welcome to west germany
what if you
rode down the the straightaway on the
bike and then get off the bike took your
helmet off and welcomed everybody
so i'm the new kid on the block i'll do
anything at that point but rich i had
never a motorcycle i'd barely been on a
schwinn
with training wheels but i'm saying oh
fine that's great so what the they now
they they got to put me in some leathers
so they find a russian so we go down to
where they they're staying using the
bikes
and there's a russian who's about five
six and maybe 145 pounds at that point
i'm 510 and probably about 180 and i'm
trying to get in to these leathers so
here i've never been on a bike now i'm
going to be on a bike
on ice with spikes i'm like this they
put the helmet on my head that barely
fits i'm squinched up and now we got to
think about i'm going to ride down the
thing and i'm going to do a scene set on
top of it so
having not been on a on a motorcycle i
don't know how i don't know how it works
so
i'm on the hand i got the handlebars and
i got everybody like the russians are
talking to me i got the guy from
czechoslovakia over the romanians you
know i got 15 different languages coming
at me at once
and all of a sudden i mean i'm revving
it up and i don't know what to do next
and i i began to let the clutch
apparently i don't know what the hell
the clutch was at that point
and fortunately
a russian rider grabbed my right hand
and you know got got the clutch back in
so it didn't this thing otherwise i
would have been i would have been
launched up there with yuri gagarin into
space at that point so we decided
we decided
this would not be such a good idea after
all so now they gotta get they get me
out of the letters
now we're gonna go do a conventional
scene set but we're late oh god so
race is supposed to start at 7 30 8
o'clock whatever it was i'm standing out
there the the only the the germans are
they're in the stands they're packed
they're you know they're chanting
they're singing
and
all of a sudden
i start to do the scene set on tape
and now we have to stop we have a
technical issue
and next thing i hear is whistling which
of course is booing and then i've got
bobbles whizzing by my head from the
stands
so i have the interpreter there and i
said what the hell what happened he said
well your producer had the pa announcer
say that just be a few more minutes
american television needs about 10 more
minutes before we can start i said what
i said he always got me killed
like i got vodka bottles ready to slice
my head open and that was uh that was
motivation the thrill of victory the
agony of
the victory i could i could have been
the guy that fell off the
ski jump it would have been better than
than that video oh
oh my god
oh
man no i i and i know jeff mason he was
one of the integral um of founding
producers and advisors of nfl network
he's he's
he's just uh he's he's one of one too
man there's no doubt about that
um so okay in the time we have left here
how did you get to monday night how did
that how did that chair
appear and then obviously the rest is
history i talked about jack quinn early
on who hired me to do the hawaii
islanders
and jacqueline always
thought of him as my trampoline he gave
me the break he gave me the break to get
into the business
and you know everybody said oh you
you know it would have happened anyway i
don't know if it would have happened
rich you got to get that initial break
so i go back to quinn and then they go
forward
to 1986 to dennis swanson
dennis swanson came over and took over
for real knowledge
and and ran abc sports alex had been
running sports and news but arlington
spent
95 of his time in news and sports is
kind of over here running by itself
gifford was doing the games with o.j
simpson and joe namath
in those years monday night football
keith was on college football i'm doing
the number two game i'm doing monday
night baseball so i've got a full plate
dennis swanson i a man i'd never met
takes over in january of 86
and two days later
it's announced that i am going to be the
new play-by-play man on monday night
football
what that came out of nowhere and that
oh
that came out of note for me and then he
dennis was a very
big college football fan
and he had seen my work over a number of
years and he said he said you just
you make the games very exciting for me
so i'm going
you never know who's listening so he was
watching a number of college games
through the years and he said i want you
in the booth i want you doing the
play-by-play
on monday night football
and i'm going to move frank to analyst
and it'll be a two-man booth
fine
uh wow you know
after i'm
actually i was very nervous thinking
damn you know i really haven't followed
the nfl that closely now i'm going to do
monday night football
and frank was resistant to make the
change at first
but then agreed to it and we wound up
doing the 86th season together
and then we
added dan deardorff in 1987 to make it a
three-man booth
and we danced that dance as the trio
through 1997
so i had the 12 seasons with
with frank and dan uh lasted through 98
and 12 with with dan as well
those were good times those were great
times
uh
you know
we were i don't want to say we were
trying to save
monday night football but the show had
began to leak a little bit i think it
sort of came back
in the late 80s and through the 90s and
then we've had you know different there
had different iterations of it uh until
it went over to espn in 2006 but that's
that's how it happened
it happened with uh
with uh
swanson putting me in that role
uh
i was not reluctant to take it but i was
nervous as a cat
and in fact in
the the first game that i did
regular season was
uh the giants at dallas
and you've got bill parcells on one
sideline tom landry on the other
sideline it's monday night football
and i was so nervous i welcomed people
to the 1976 football season
and then i caught myself and i looked at
frank and i said well it's already been
a long year
anyway and that that's how it that's how
it got underway and you know here it is
uh 20 years on monday night and going on
16 now on sunday night
is it the same was it the same thing as
it currently is now that you you get
times before the games with the coaches
and interview them and if so does that
mean you you had your first one of your
first broadcaster coaches meetings with
with landry and parcells is that the way
it went that was the case
landry and then uh uh
he had paul hackett in that meeting as
well hackett i think was the offensive
coordinator of the
of the cowboys and then parcells came
into the meeting
uh and
it was funny because joe morris who was
their number one back was holding out
and he was holding out at that point
and uh
you know if i'm new to the game
at least i didn't know bill at that
point so i said uh
how big of a deal is it if joe doesn't
play he goes
not a deal at all like that he's like
okay you know
bill would always
not um
denigrate you
in any malicious way but it was always
like no matter what question you'd ask
bill had to be the contrarian in terms
of an answer anyway i i loved part i
wound up you know loving parcells
covering her for a ton of years
he almost became the analyst on on
monday night football in 2000 had an
opportunity to do it
yes he did yes and and passed on it
yeah i know i'm jumping around here but
but in night yeah no in uh
so you know frank leaves after 97 dear
dwarfs gone after 98 i worked two
seasons with boomer assistant
98 with with deardorff and 99 just the
two of us in 2000 don olmeier comes in
to produce the show and he wants to he
wants to do something really different
and the really different thing that he
did of course is we hired dennis miller
but that's a different story before we
hired dennis though
that role was going to go to parcells
because bill was now leaving football he
coached the jets
now you got the whole thing going on
with bill's going to move into the front
office maybe this is the whole belichick
year this is the not going to be the hc
of the nyj year right so you got
belichick
getting the jets job and then walking
away from it to go to new england
parcells going does he really want to do
front office work
or does he want to go to abc
and bill and i
had two very very long discussions on
the phone and the thing about parcels
was
he always had all of the answers right
we're you're asking the questions but we
spent
two long two very long conversations on
the phone he must have asked 50
questions
wanted to know how everything would work
it was great and they realized he's such
an intelligent man
his knowledge of football of course is
is superb
and
at the end of the day
he said uh
at the end of our second conversation he
said i don't know if i'm gonna take this
job or not
i try i try to tell him hey take the job
come on out here we'll play golf and do
the whole thing
uh i want him to take the job and then
he said i don't know if i'll take the
job he said if i do
i'll be the best analyst ever
ever
and i said bill i said that's all i want
to hear because i don't want this to be
a halfway house for you
guys get out of coaching
and come back into coaching right we've
seen a whole bunch room so if you
haven't gotten your coaching jollies
if they're not out of your out of your
body
this means too much to the rest of us
and that's when he said what he said
about he'd be the best ever and of
course there was a part of me that knew
that he had to go back to coaching at
some point of course that happened in o3
when he began to coach the cowboys for
four seasons
uh he would he would have been terrific
i agree because that's the one thing you
know you know obviously madden is one of
the all-time greats out of because he
talked in a language that uh people
completely understood and from folksy to
playing to
just
just describe that describing the
obviously collinsworth has that gene in
him as well the way that you could just
describe something and it doesn't sound
like you're
filled with jargon it's just
normal plain english that makes sense
you know and i think bill would have
been great at that oh yeah and with
madden too and columns they make it fun
too they make not only interesting
but there's a there's a
lightness to it too as well
there's none of the you know the three
technique and you know the wide not what
we get into that too but you you got to
come away from that stuff and see the
bigger broader picture and i've been
fortunate with you know john and chris
over the last almost 20 years now uh it
doesn't get any better than that and
they you know what it is so rich
it's communication
those guys know how to communicate they
know how to connect with the audience
and that's why you know john just he
understood what it was he understood
what what it means to listen to somebody
i mean to me i've always thought
would i enjoy myself in other words if
i'm if i'm a listener
i i want to i want to make sure that i'm
i'm what i'm saying is interesting
informative
uh
and on point
with with me as as a viewer so you're
trying to put yourself in the viewer's
position what does he need to know what
does he what does he have to know what's
fun to know what's different um
and you know you you're trying to you
know kind of
flip the mirror a little bit to think of
yourself as a listener as well as a
communicator right and then talk about
things that you know and again
normally um or plainly i guess would be
the way to put it and you know madden
you had a
seat next to him hearing the way that he
would communicate you know
the the thing that will always live with
me isn't from his game but from his pro
football hall of fame speech about the
busts talking to each other it just was
such a uh it was such a fan thing to say
like you know
and you know do they talk and what do
they talk about when the lights go out
and then one of the last lines he said
is like you know and i'm going to be
having one of those busts
in there talking you know forever and
ever talking about whatever and that was
like almost poetry you know and
you know what i mean like that's
so
and
i i i miss him oh my god
he's he's one of the smartest people
ever i mean
you look at john he's kind of larger
than life and he's got all the sound
effects and the boom and the whole thing
and but people don't understand this is
a man who knows a lot about a lot
and
in my seven years with john i mean we
had
some great great times
and most of them
dealt with like dinners or discussions
that we had about things other than
football
and we we spent enough time on football
we got it we knew it and we're doing a
game you know every week but john could
discuss
anything
he was a very curious man
very and of course going around the
country that's what he always wanted to
do he he loved you know stopping in the
coffee shop in goodland kansas
and getting to know the people and
that's that's i think part of the reason
that john was able to connect
as a communicator with like every
demographic in every part of the country
well al uh i'm gonna finish up with you
the way i'm planning to finish up with
all the other interviews for for this 10
uh part series of just getting started
on nfl voices and broadcasters and it's
the best piece of advice you received in
your career what what was it and from
whom well i would say
it's kind of it's a it's a little odd in
a way but i'll never forget i loved kurt
goudy as a broadcaster loved him and i
got to do the 1972 world series with him
when i was doing the cincinnati regime
and we won the pennant
and i actually had met kurt when i was
in college
and he was doing the red sox and i i
played a tape for him
at spring training
uh
so
he knew about me now we're doing the
world series together
and i'll never forget one of the things
he said he was here toward the end of
his career and i'm starting mine
basically
and he said to me never get jaded
i thought really i'm having too much fun
but as you got older
and you would you know proceed on in the
business if things necessarily didn't
work out for you
if you know you didn't get whatever
opportunity that you thought somebody
else got that you should have gotten uh
or you get tired of you know you you
just
grow weary of whatever travel or that
maybe the sameness if you're doing
baseball 162 games a year
so it was a very odd thing
to hear when i was 27
but as i moved along through the years i
thought to myself you know what that's
right this is one of the greatest jobs
ever created
ever
and i keep going back to you know being
the sixth seven-year-old walking in
debbie's field
and here i am on the other end of
the la of the life spectrum and i still
get excited about it i still get excited
about it walking into a stadium fills up
the noise the whole thing the drama of
the games themselves uh it's never gone
away but i keep thinking about what kurt
said don't get jaded and i never will
you're the man now michaels love you i
love you best to linda um because she's
been part of everything that we just
talked about for all those years as well
um and um let's i i this just scratched
the surface which is amazing i literally
could talk to you forever but i
appreciate the time you're the best
richie anytime take care see you soon
you got that's al michael's here on just
getting started the one and only al
michaels they truly broke the mold
with al and
he is at the top of his game as great as
he's ever been and what makes al so
great
is so few people can meet a moment like
al and we all know
him meeting the moment for say the
olympics
say uh when malcolm butler stepped in
and intercepted a pass in the super bowl
to win a game for one team that looked
like it was about to lose
and
uh beat a team that looked like it was
about to win it's the least expected
moment
you could ever imagine from a guy that
had to be so deep down on al's list of
players that he had to study and know
and know by name and uniform number and
malcolm butler
and that's meeting a moment and then
there's also living in a moment
obviously again his miracle play uh the
famed 2011 call
on monday night football of antonio
freeman
juggling a ball that looked like it had
hit the ground but he really had caught
it he did what
i mean
sometimes you just a perfect call
is somebody living in the moment and
saying what's in our own heads without
obviously the curse words like he did
what i mean it's a perfect call
of a moment like antonio freeman and
then of course living in the moment like
farve doing what he did
uh the night that uh he played after his
father had passed away i mean i could
truly go
on and on those are two special
aspects of a sports broadcaster that al
personifies together but it's also
knowing the nuts and bolts not just down
in distance i mean
when nbc added
terry mccauley uh an official a rules
expert to their sunday night broadcast
because my buddy mike from back in the
day at nfl network mike pereira was
doing such a great job on fox as a rules
analyst everybody started adding one to
their national broadcast and they added
terry mcauley to the nbc sunday night
football broadcast and my first thought
was why
because al is the rules expert al is the
guy who knows
what is in the rule book and whether it
applies to something that's under review
or something that should be reviewed or
why a clock is stopped he is truly
unbelievable
like that and in terms of meeting the
moment you just heard what his
and living in the moment and knowing the
moment
uh all together that makes him
you know arguably the greatest who's
ever done it
but the living in the moment is so tough
to do to know what you're seeing in real
time and know what it means and know how
to put it in perspective and also know
how to
react to it emotionally that you at home
can plug into um hearing his advice that
he got
uh from back in his day from kurt gowdy
don't get jaded
and you could just hear it in the hitch
in al's voice
uh when it's time for a season kickoff
like we're hearing this week
or a big moment that he's going to call
in week four
on sunday night football which is the
greatest piece of filet mignon's steak
that the 2021 nfl schedule is going to
serve up
which is tom brady returning to new
england
uh with the buccaneers taking on
uh at the time of this podcast dropping
mac jones healthy and ready to roll as a
rookie starter wearing tom brady's
college number 10 as tb12 returns
that you know that somebody's called so
much and been there and done that
calling an olympics moment that is the
number one moment of the 20th sport
century calling many super bowls like
the one that i just mentioned with
malcolm butler calling a world series
during an earthquake doing everything
from minor league baseball as you heard
in hawaii
and
also doing
a wide world of sports and nearly dying
in the process
because he nearly wiped out on an ice
motorcycle or had a bunch of east
germans getting very angry that
he was holding up the start of that
event
that after having been there and done
all that that the
broadcast that means the most to him
that
gives him the goosebumps is his latest
one and then his next one
so
the greats get the advice and the greats
absorb the advice and then the greats
live the advice
and
al is
just the best and i'm honored to know
him he spoke at my 50th birthday party
he's you know
he and his wife and mine uh me and my
wife go out to dinner and i just hear
all these stories half the stories that
you heard here tonight on this podcast
are stories that i've heard before and
them even though i have them on my daily
show which you can also hear on the
cumulus podcast network the rich eisen
show all three hours every day sometimes
i don't have the forum for him to tell
these stories
and
you know that tommy lasorda story i knew
it i it's one of my favorites
of tommy lasorda
talking about
that that the dodgers even though they
already have vince scully should hire
this kid
and tell them that to al campanis and
the reason why he knew
al was so good at the broadcast is
because
tommy's been ejected so much that he's
actually had to listen to al's
play-by-play
i just love these stories and i can't
wait to bring more of them to you
throughout this
entire series of special just getting
started
where jim nance and next week joe buck
will come along and tell you their
stories and kevin harlan of westwood 1
and michael strahan and aaron andrews of
fox and we're adding more guests as we
speak over this 10-week span
so keep on looking back here every
single wednesday for a latest episode of
just getting started this special
podcast series of voices of the nfl
rolls on we appreciate you taking in
this one with the greatest
you